es ist eines der großen rätsel der
astronomie die fermi blasen im zentrum
unserer milchstraße erst vor elf jahren
wurden sie überhaupt entdeckt wie und
warum sind diese gigantischen strukturen
entstanden doch möglicherweise kann
jetzt das neue röntgenteleskop rosita
zur aufklärung der galaktischen super
babbels beitragen nichts und sei aus dem
flugzeug geht es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ja nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
die rede ist von einer super blase oder
besser von zweien deren abmessungen
alles andere was man sich vor ihrer
entdeckung überhaupt vorstellen konnte
sprengt eine super blasen doppelstruktur
im zentrum der milchstraße aufgespürt
wurde sie vor elf jahren 2010 vom
gleichnamigen gamma teleskop der nasa
dieses hat der gammastrahlung
aufgefangen die die energiereichen
teilchen strom aussenden beide blasen
scheinen senkrecht auf der ebene der
milchstraße zu stehen und tragen nach
unten und nach oben heraus wenn man sie
mit bloßem auge sehen könnte dann würden
sie von der erde aus am nachthimmel zwei
drittel unseres sichtfeldes einnahmen es
handelt sich also um blasen aus
schnellen gasen und gammastrahlen die
unglaubliche 50 tausend lichtjahre aus
der galaxie ebene herausragende
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vermuten dass diese vermin blasen durch
vorgängen im zentrum der milchstraße
entstehen doch der genaue ursprung und
ihre genaue struktur sind bis heute
nicht vollständig aufgeklärt war es der
ausbruch ein superjets der von dem heute
passiven schwarzen loch im zentrum der
galaxie ausging oder war es eine kaskade
von supernovae im zentrum der galaxie
die sich zu zeiten der sternentstehung
zu einer solchen super blase bildeten
kann das neue röntgenteleskop rosita
dieses rätsel um die galaktischen
superbes lösen alle spannenden infos zu
diesem thema gibt es jetzt hier bei
pixum science im schnitt schafft da ist
die wissenschaft sich einig dass
deutsche röntgenteleskop rosita ist eine
riesige chance für die astronomie das
sonnenteleskop wird in den kommenden
jahren den himmel durchmustern und dabei
fundamentale fragen des universums
beantworten die chancen stehen also
nicht schlecht dass er sieht da endlich
licht ins geheimnis der dunklen energie
bringen könnte rosita könnte damit also
eine antwort auf die wohl
faszinierendste frage der astronomie und
physik geben und das wiederum könnte
eine fundamentale revolution der physik
mit sich bringt wie ist das max planck
institut für extraterrestrische physik
mpe auf seiner webseite schreibt und
nicht nur das rosita soll eine art
kosmische inventur des universums
ermöglichen galaxien die milliarden
lichtjahre entfernt sind könnten mit
hilfe des röntgen teleskops die bislang
unerreichter auflösung erforscht werden
letztendlich soll dann eine himmelskarte
entstehen die nicht weniger als die
entwicklung des universums april möglich
wird das alles mit der hilfe von
röntgenstrahlung die die strukturen des
alls sichtbar machen werden deswegen
auch der name rosita der führenden
service imagine telescope array steht im
visier stehen nicht nur verdunkelte
schwarze löcher in nahen galaxien und
röntgen quält wie etwa supernova
überrest in unserer galaxie untersucht
werden sollen vor allem bis zu 100000
galaxienhaufen also ansammlungen von
tausenden einzelne galaxien die durch
die schwerkraft miteinander verbunden
sind möglich für deren analyse durch das
gas das sich in ihnen befindet um bis zu
100 millionen grad heiß ist wegen dieser
hohen temperatur sendet es
röntgenstrahlung aus die fachleute
wollen durch die verteilung der galaxien
hoffen herausfinden wie sich das
universum ausdehnt wies damals aussah
und natürlich auch wie es heute aussieht
bis zu 6 milliarden jahre soll rosetta
zurückblicken können dazu der
astrophysiker michael freiberg dank
seiner empfindlichkeit sowie energie und
winkel auflösung kann sieht den gesamten
röntgen himmel mit bisher unerreichter
tief und kartieren und bereits wenige
zeit nach dem start im sommer 2009 10
konnte rosita die erste erfolge
vermelden erst im vergangenen jahr 2020
hatten die forschenden vom mpi eine
verblüffende entdeckung gemacht eine
große struktur in der milchstraße die
wie eine gigantische sanduhr aussieht
und die seerosen sind wirklich sehr
ähnlich zu den fermi blasen dazu hieß es
in der pressemitteilung des
forschungsteams die röntgen emissionen
die von rosita in seinem mittleren
energie beim von 0,6 bis 1,0
beobachtet wird zeigt dass die blasen
eine ausdehnung von mehreren kilo pa6
oder bis zu 50.000 lichtjahren im
durchmesser haben und damit fast so groß
sind wie die milchstraße selbst diese
musiker bleiben zeigen auffallende
morphologische ähnlichkeiten mit dem
bereits bekannten fernglas die das fermi
teleskope im bereich der gammastrahlen
entdeckte sie sind aber größer und
energierecht doch wie entstehen solche
galaktischen super babbels die
beteiligten forschenden gehen davon aus
dass die scharfen grenzflächen dieser
blasen entlang von schockwellen laufen
diese wurden möglicherweise durch einen
massiven energieeintrag aus dem inneren
unserer galaxie in den galaktischen
halos verursacht hat so sagt einer der
beteiligten mb forscher peter praet
solch eine erklärung wurde bereits
früher für die fermi blasen
vorgeschlagen mit aero sita ist jetzt
ihr volles ausmaß und ihre morphologie
offensichtlich gewirkt doch lassen sich
diese ergebnisse so auch eins zu eins
auch die vermieter asn im zentrum
unserer milchstraße übertragen oder sind
sie gab von verschiedenen himmels
ereignissen im zentrum verursacht worden
materie muss hier mit hoher
geschwindigkeit in die gashülle um
unsere milchstraße geschleudert worden
sein erst vor zwei jahren hatte ein
internationales forschungsteam eine neue
erklärung möglichkeit für die
mysteriösen fermi blasen zur diskussion
gestellt demnach muss es vor rund einer
milliarde jahren in der milchstraße
einen dramatischen ausbruch gegeben
haben es handelt sich möglicherweise um
eines der energiereichsten ereignisse
ihrer geschichte die fachleute sprechen
von einer wahren explosion der stern
bildung innerhalb von kürzester zeit
könnten dabei fünf prozent der gesamten
sternen masse unserer galaxie entstanden
sein doch nicht nur dass dieser ausbruch
möglicherweise hunderttausende von
supernova-explosionen witzig gebracht
genau das könnte eine erklärung die
rätselhaften verlassensein dazu schrieb
das forschungsteam in der studie schon
ein kleiner anteil der dabei
freigesetzten energie wäre ausreichend
um die energie der röntgen ausströme zu
erklären die jüngste stern bildung
kombiniert mit der aktivität von
sagittarius aussterben dieser daher eine
plausible erklärung für die beobachteten
ausströmen digitales stern das ist die
bezeichnung die supermassereichen
schwarzen loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße
klar ist jedenfalls wo gamma strahlung
entsteht ist oft auch röntgenstrahlung
aufzuspüren die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler des mpi namen also die
daten des röntgensatelliten rosat noch
einmal genauer inspiziert dieser war im
juni vor 31 jahren 1990 ins weltall
gestartet zum ersten mal sollten mit
seiner hilfe der gesamte himmel auf
röntgenquellen untersucht werden denn
schon damals wusste man dass
röntgenstrahlen vor allem weil besonders
energiereichen und heißen prozessen im
universum entstehen oft beteiligt sind
daran neutronensterne oder schwarze
löcher und tatsächlich war hier unten
strahlung detektiert worden allerdings
war diese zu schwach um sie eindeutig zu
interpretieren dass man heute mit ihrer
sieht da schon besser aufgestellt zu der
analyse mit aero sie da sagt der
astrophysiker michael freiberg vom mpi
in einem interview mit hyperraum tv
diese kameras zeichnen wirklich jedes
einzelnen photon auch man kann wirklich
an jedem morgen photonen die energie zu
stellen die ankunftszeit den ort und den
detektor und wenn man weiß wo das tennis
profi angeschaut hat auch den ort am
himmel hyperraum tv und das video sind
uns hier oben verlinkt und amerika ist
eine beobachtung von der erde aus ist
nicht möglich denn die röntgenstrahlung
wird von der erdatmosphäre absorbiert
und ist somit vom boden aus nicht
nachzuweisen doch wie können die
gemessenen röntgen daten dann den
bereits bekannten strahlungsquellen
zugeordnet werden und wie erfolgt dann
die bestimmung der entfernung dafür
nutzen physikerinnen und physiker
beobachtungen in anderen wellenlängen
doch die zuordnung dieser ganzen daten
bedeutet eine menge arbeit und rosita
steckt noch in den kinderschuhen
zunächst erfolgt die katalogisierung der
röntgenstrahlung am himmel feststeht es
fehlen noch weitere wichtige messungen
anderer wellenlängen um den ursprung der
aero sita blasen ausmachen zu können
dazu muss also zunächst mal die
sogenannte multi wellen astronomie
weiter ausgebaut werden doch schon jetzt
hilft die entdeckung der aero sita
blasen den fachleuten den kosmischen
kreislauf der materie in und um die
milchstraße und anderer galaxien besser
zu verstehen langfristig will man sodann
auch den mysteriösen termin blasen auf
die schliche kommen so die hoffnung der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
und es gibt noch mehr gigantische blasen
die aus dem zentrum unserer milchstraße
entspringen oder sind das alles
phänomene ein und desselben ereignisses
unbekannte katastrophe riesige blasen im
zentrum der milchstraße anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
haben